not much light no ventilators
little space eight families live in this
housing complex
today starts early for olamide without
breakfast but with daily chores
the 18 year old shares 10 square meters
with her mother and her younger sister
she's trying to help her family by
putting her own needs
on hold life for me now is very very
difficult and very tough
because sometimes i need something but
because
we don't have enough money i just have
to keep it to myself
not to tell my mom and stuff like that
schools are closed due to the pandemic
well amida's mom is an elementary
teacher
she has to stay at home without a salary
and is struggling to provide for her two
daughters
i'm a mother supposed to be taking good
care of them as well
anything they want for me i supposed to
be giving them because i don't want them
to look outside because they
are girls outside means ojo
one of the poorer neighborhoods of lagos
some girls slide into prostitution to
make money
and some boys become criminals olamide
grew up here
she's looking for a different path
through ballet
this is the same neighborhood but it
feels like a different world
are you guys ready so we will be doing
a very simple combination today a class
of 12 students
trains in this makeshift dance room
twice a week
one of them is olamide some are as young
as six
daniel a self-taught professional dancer
is teaching them for free
to keep them off the streets
some of them are not going to become
professional dancers we know that
because children come in and go
the training they get here can be
applied in any area of their life
olamide was one of his first students in
2017
she says it's never too late to stop
with ballet
not even for me in my thirties
like this yes and you go plie
and a smiling olamide
dancing she says helps her cope with her
daily struggles
when i come to dance i forget about
everything
behind because dance makes me feel happy
and making to express my feelings
through it's how i feel i danced
out just forget about the past and now
in the future
their stage improvised the streets
of ojo
the contrast couldn't be bigger for some
it's a welcome distraction
others are skeptical because of the
religious belief of ninja they feel that
it is indecent for a lady to actually
lift their legs up and their
lower area will be seen and but where
it's not like that polamide's day
doesn't end here after ballet she learns
to sew at this shop
learning a trade that may finance her
studies one day
she keeps practicing ballet while she's
sewing
i don't care what people's reactions are
because i'm doing my thing i'm me forget
about everybody behind me i just focus
on myself
because i know what i want for myself
olamide
may never dance on the big international
stages
but dancing gives her strength something
she needs
to overcome the difficulties she faces